welcome back it is national something on
a stick day a holiday all about the
endless possibilities of getting
creative with your food rocky is
celebrating live at crunchies what are
you making now rocky
girl i am making a squid ink hot dog
have you ever ever heard of that no
unless you've been to crunchy so let's
go ahead and talk before i start you
know creating my masterpiece here let's
just talk about what's on the menu in
terms of toppings and condiments how
creative can people get oh yeah we have
seven different sauce and three
different kind of seasonings nice so
there's no rule you get to put whatever
you like i like it well yeah we can add
more of the sauce to be savory more
savory than already is okay so for squid
ink we have what would you suggest for
my squidding hot dogs i would say we
usually have a recommended combination
over there so for that i'll recommend
number three which is
okay ketchup i always love ketchup on my
hot dogs
wow okay i'm not as good as your crew
back here that looks perfect
and then honey mustard right here
oh my god i am so excited to try this
whoa okay so what am i going to taste
when i bite into this
you'll first you'll taste mozzarella
cheese okay
very good okay and also some of the hot
dogs as well okay and what kind of meat
is in here
beef hot though
and while i'm trying to bite this what
is that so it's a hot dog that we cut it
into a little edge it looks like squid
legs
oh man
oh my
that is good wow okay
you guys are made to lose that
i have ketchup and honey mustard all
over my face so june
let's move on to something a little more
sweet because that's obviously really
savory
i understand this is the rice cake hot
dog yeah we definitely recommend it with
sugar coated right here
go ahead sugarcoat you guys you can
sugarcoat a hot dog in here
that is crazy okay
boom and tell everybody what i'm biting
into here
almoche soft chewy
different texture
it's like a mochi rice ball
oh my god this is so good okay so you
guys have an instagram yes we do
crunches lv
and we are also doing promotion for a
whole week at blue diamond location for
a soft drink for any of their purchases
and you guys also have some really
unique juices too to go with everything
what are those we do we have a couple of
refreshers right there right there also
different kind of lemonades as well
okay well i am this is delicious i'm
gonna finish both of these guys i'll
send it back to you celebrate something
honest